legendary nascar driver jimmy johnson is
making a mark this giving tuesday the
seven-time nascar cup series champion is
one of the greatest nascar drivers of
all time but he says he wants to be
known for more than just a race car
driver johnson represents two charity
organizations the american legion which
supports veterans the jimmy johnson
foundation which focuses on public
public education this year he aims to
raise 248 000
for veterans in just one day jimmy joins
us right now jimmy welcome how are you
doing doing great glad to be on the show
yeah of course now you said you wanted
to raise 248 000
in just one day why is that so important
to you well last year the american
legion had an amazing year on giving
tuesday and raised around 150 000 so
we'd love to challenge my fans and
everybody watching on this very special
day uh to raise more and we'd love to
incentivize people to go to legion.org
backslash 48 make a 48 donation
there's so many important services that
are out there but being with the
american legion over the course of the
year and looking at their focus on on
giving back to the veterans um suicide
ironically is is a really really big
problem and one of many causes that
they're working hard to help the public
understand and every dollar raised will
help in their cause and help serve the
the people that defend our country is
there a particular significance to 48 oh
my god tony tony i did that exact same
thing
in the green room i said to jimmy why 48
and because he's such a nice guy he had
an expression that looked like is she
serious am i supposed to know well yes
we're both surprised
because this is great it's his car no
race car now and i know
tony big fan long time viewer
i know but he was so nice he said uh car
number
all right so it wasn't just me okay i
mean i know you were the ally driver
sorry we are so sorry i know it is
totally fine we are so sorry
but let's talk about the jimmy johnson
foundation too
because you have a big goal for that as
well yeah my wife and i um have always
given back in different ways growing up
and we were challenged to start a
foundation in my early days starting in
nascar and the foundation is now 16
years old there have been many causes
that we've supported and have paid
attention to um and most recently it's
really been public education and in the
areas where my wife and i both grew up
and then where we live in north carolina
and your wife's name is chandra there
you go and you've been around a lot
longer or about a lot more often since
you retired last year we're retired in
quotes we'll talk about what you're
going to do yeah retirement
what's it been like uh to step back from
nascar and think about your next chapter
it was interesting we were chatting a
little bit about you know that plan b as
an athlete and what that might look like
and i knew i would stay racing but i had
no idea i would end up in the carvana
indy car for chip ganassi racing i mean
indycar was always a dream for me um
as a young kid but my path took me to
nascar so when chip gave me the
opportunity to drive a car and drive an
indy car and feel it and you know
understand what it was about it blew my
mind and quickly became a point of
interest for me and i had my first
season and that beautiful indy car had a
wonderful time and but they were calling
you a rookie indy car driver did that
feel weird to be called a rookie
considering 45 year old rookie yeah 46
year old rookie considering all the
stuff you bring to the table yeah i mean
experience is one thing but the cars in
the series was totally different for me
so i truly was rookie what's the biggest
difference between the two the cars are
about two to three times the the
performance level of a cup car
especially in the tight turns and on the
brakes uh so to relearn and and kind of
recalibrate my senses for the faster car
has been quite and with nascar you're
you're bumping and rubbing around the
corners and edges but now in indycar you
don't do that right you can but your
success rate's pretty low okay um yeah
with the open wheels and the very
fragile nature of the cars uh touching
is really not something you want to do
in an indy car word on the streets is
that you have your eye on the indy 500
next year you could clarify that if you
want you could elaborate you could say
stop talking gail where does this stand
for you i'm so glad you asked gail you
know
i'm working towards it i've been in the
indycar twice now on an oval and in fact
was at the indianapolis motor speedway
um we we hope to get something put
together soon there's just a lot of
moving pieces and unfortunately nothing
to announce just yet okay awesome stuff
all right here we appreciate you joining
us make a 48 donation
it's the car number people that's right
the card number that's tony i i just saw
the name ally across your your uh your
get up i know i felt like i was like the
two of those but it wasn't nice
thank you for yeah we'll be right back